hey guys it is the 14th of September
today my name is Jess McDowell and
you're tuned into gamespot knees it
turns out Australians one of the early
wants to get a new leader today as
Nintendo has now appointed a new
president tatsumi kimishima has been
named as nintendo's new president and
successor to satoru iwata who tragically
passed away earlier this year kimishima
is by no means new to the company though
his resume includes serving as chief
financial officer of the pokemon company
and director of Nintendo America for
many years kimishima officially enters
the role on sep tember 16 nintendo have
also created a number of fellow roles to
act as expert advisors for kimishima
crater a punch-out and current general
manager of Nintendo's research and
development division Kenya Takeda has
been appointed as technology fellow
while Shigeru Miyamoto the creator of
Mario will serve as creative fellow
Metal Gear Solid 5 has received a ps4
patch to correct a bug which could
corrupt your save files previously
taking quiet along on mission 29 or
mission 42 could result in a bug being
triggered that messes up your saves
Konami have now given the all clear on
that one and you're free to take quiet
along on as many missions as you damn
well please without fear on top of that
fix konami has also announced that there
will be daily log in bonuses throughout
the duration of tokyo game show tokyo
game show runs from September 17 until
sep tember 20 and the daily bonuses will
update at one a.m. PST for the duration
of the show Microsoft has said the new
xbox one experience update will improve
the system in all sorts of ways
including speed and responsiveness on
the latest episode of Major Nelson radio
Xbox engineering boss Mike Guevara said
that popular gaming features will load
up to fifty percent faster with the
update he didn't specify exactly which
popular gaming features but he is
promising Xbox users that the update
will deliver a new level of speed and
on Cygnus and we'll also introduce
backwards compatibility for Xbox 360
titles and you guide a redesigned home
and a new community section elsewhere in
the podcast Jabara emphasized the
difficulty of integrating Windows 10
with xbox one and said that the team is
creating a highly customized version of
the OS built specifically for the Xbox
one which they're calling one core let
me know down in that comment box if
you're keen for the Xbox one update you
can head to gamespot we've got news on
need for speed on PC getting delayed and
halo vibes dynamic resolutions that is
everything I have for you today as
always let me know what you cared about
and I will catch the same time tomorrow